[Music]
space
justin
pedro it's great to be together with all
of you here today
this demonstrates really nato solidarity
that we stand together
uh facing uh a critical moment for our
security caused by the brutal invasion
of
russia of a peaceful
country in europe ukraine
president putin's war on ukraine has
shattered peace in europe it has shaken
the international order
and it continues to take devastating
toll on the ukrainian people
but putin seriously underestimated
ukraine and he seriously underestimated
the strength and the unity of nato and
our friends and partners around the
world
we have imposed unprecedented costs on
russia
we have stepped up our support for
ukraine helping to uphold its right to
self-defense
and
we have implemented historic
reinforcements
on nato's collective defense
with thousands more troops reinforcing
the eastern part of our alliance
including here in latvia
i strongly welcome that allies including
canada spain and the united states
are deploying hundreds more troops to
our multinational presence here at the
adarshe base in latvia
so justin pedro thank you for your
personal leadership and your commitment
to our collective security
canada has led nato's battlegroup in
latvia for years
with skill and dedication
a powerful demonstration
of your commitment to transatlantic
security
spain
is leading by example by deploying
additional troops ships and jets to
strengthen our defensive posture in
europe
it was really an honor to meet
your forces here today
from both sides of the atlantic
they represent the spirit of all our
allies
all for one and one for all
nato is a defensive alliance
we do not see conflict with russia
our ultimate responsibility
is to keep our 1 billion citizens safe
this means we must do everything
possible to prevent the conflict from
spreading beyond ukraine
and our presence here in latvia sends a
unmistakable message of unity and
resolve
our commitment to article 5 of the
washington treaty is absolute
and we will do whatever it takes
to protect and defend
all allies
so cristianis justin and pedro
at this dangerous moment for our
security we stand united for our people
and our values europe and north america
together in nato thank you
obviously
minister
justin um
thank you so much for your warm welcome
as well we continue to strengthen the
relationship between canada and latvia
prime minister sanchez pedro it's good
to see you i know how important the
contribution of spain is to the success
of the mission here
nato secretary general stoltenberg thank
you jens for being with us today it's
extremely important
nato truly is multinational it was
absolutely amazing to see the
culminating military exercise of our
troops from different nations including
those of canada latvia and spain
training together it was great to be
here and i'm also very happy to be
joined today
by minister anand our minister of
national defense and the chief of
defense staff general heir
we had a very productive day today on
top of my different bilateral meetings
with
christianis prime minister currents
prime minister sanchez and nato
secretary general stoltenberg i also met
with president levitz of latvia to
discuss ukraine and a broad range of
topics in addition this morning
cristianis was able to organize that we
were joined virtually by the prime
minister of estonia
and the prime minister of lithuania
we agreed to deepen the partnership
between canada and the baltic countries
especially at this time of uncertainty
professionalism
last month canada announced the
deployment of up to 460 members of the
canadian armed forces to nato through
operation reassurance this announcement
includes more troops here in latvia as
well as the deployment of an additional
frigate and maritime patrol aircraft
a total of 540 calf personnel are now
deployed here in latvia and
approximately 130 more will join in the
coming weeks well today i can further
announce
an early
multi-year renewal of operation
reassurance to support nato in central
and eastern europe
this mission was set to expire next year
and in light of the situation in europe
we decided to renew it ahead of schedule
operation reassurance is the caf's
support to nato's assurance and
deterrence measures the troops here are
not only defending latvia or eastern
europe they're defending all nato allies
including canada they're defending our
freedom and our security that's why this
work is so important especially in the
face of continued russian aggression
foreign
today in particular during international
women's day i want to thank all the
brave women who serve in the canadian
armed forces for their outstanding work
and all the women who serve in armed
forces around the world
canada will continue to be an ally and
partner to help defend our shared values
and we will continue to be there for
ukraine
and now i'd like to turn the mic over to
canada's minister of national defense
anita anand
thank you prime minister it is an honor
for me to be here especially on
international women's day
i was here less than one month ago and
it is so good to be back here today to
see the troops
and to thank them for their service my
visit in early february and a number of
engagements thereafter including the
recent nato defense ministers meeting in
brussels made clear
that operations like operation
reassurance represent the very best that
nato has to offer
this is the message that i hear in every
meeting
and continue to hear
in response to this message
and to putin's further aggression we
announced on february 22nd
up to 460 more troops to nato through
operation reassurance on top of the 500
already here and the deployment of as
the prime minister mentioned an
additional frigate and a maritime patrol
aircraft to reinforce nato's eastern
flank
now
as the prime minister just announced we
are going even further
today we are renewing our support by
extending operation reassurance mission
one year ahead of time
this announcement reflects our deep
commitment to the long-term security
stability and
interoperability of the nato alliance
secretary
i want to conclude by expressing my
gratitude to our canadian armed forces
by
continuing to put service before self
and for continuing canada's enduring
commitment to latvia
to nato's eastern flank
and to our collective security at home
and abroad
and i extend this appreciation to all
who serve
and who are here today
thank you merci baldis i now am happy to
pass the mic over to prime minister
sanchez thank you
thank you very much mr thank you very
much my dear friends
as prime minister to those said today
eighth march should have been a day of
celebration of women and girls in
ukraine
unfortunately putting
brutal aggression is forcing them to
flee their country or fight for their
lives
i would like to pay an homage today to
all of them and reassure that we will
stand by their side
i would like to thank the president and
the prime minister of odatria for
organizing this visit
i am very happy to share it with my
friend
justin prime minister to though this
country commands this battle group and
with nato secretary general jens
stoltenberg
we're here to support to our baltic
allies
and friends in this very difficult times
and to send a very clear message to
president putin nato allies are united
and the transatlantic bond is stronger
than ever
i want to insist once again
our main commitment is with peace
nato is a defensive alliance as
secretary general of nato has said
and all our actions so far are
deterrence efforts to avoid
confrontation
spanish troops are the second largest
contingent here in nadas's battle group
and i want to recognize our soldiers
dedication solidarity and
professionalism
we are increasing our deployment by with
157 additional soldiers and we are also
ready to fulfill our commitment through
the graduate response plans
i would like to reaffirm
spain's unwarying support to create
we have delivered several
tons of humanitarian aid and military
equipment
spain will also be up to the challenge
that represents the dreadful
humanitarian crisis caused by this
terrible war with over 1.7 million
people fleeing their country
we will stay by the ukrainian government
and by the ukrainian people to withstand
putin's unjustified attack
this is an act of aggression
not only to europe's security but also
to what europe represents which is
democracy mutilateralism and freedom i
think
this is
foreign
good afternoon gentlemen murray brewster
with cbc news it's prime minister
trudeau
allies have been shipping to ukraine
anti-aircraft weapons
and entertainment weapons candidates and
state governments both of those
capabilities are in short supply in the
canadian military the canadian army does
not have a dedicated surface-to-air
defense system will your government
commit to an urgent procurement to cover
those capability gaps and will your
government commit
to meeting nato's benchmark standard of
two percent of gdp and defense spending
first of all we understand the urgency
that
is presented right now in the world with
ukrainians standing strong against this
illegal russian
invasion
and that's why we have sent
aid we have sent weapons we will
continue to send support to ukrainians
as they stand to defend not just their
country
but defend democracy defend the values
that underpin democracy
and in fact defend us all
those weapons are much more useful right
now and in the coming weeks in the hands
of ukrainian soldiers
fighting for their lives
than they would be in canadian hands but
of course we need to make sure we
replace those weapons rapidly and that
we continue to invest in the equipment
uh that leads
our armed forces uh to be able to
continue to contribute not just uh in
places like here in latvia but
everywhere around the world where we are
called on to do i had an excellent
conversation with secretary general
stoltenberg earlier this afternoon in
which i talked about indeed our approach
to continuing to invest
in our military and making sure that
canada is always there to stand up for
us
democracy
[Music]
[Music]
is
uh
[Music]
um
yeah hello
so far
well i'm mina kewalo from
i think on behalf of all the spanish
journalists here today so um so far the
response through sanctions has not
stopped putting um what should be the
path from now on how far can nato go
and how far can the european union go as
well do you consider the possibility of
stopping buying oil and gas from russia
just like the u.s has proposed and do
you think that argelian gas could be a
solution to supply all eu european
countries and prime minister sanchez as
far as spain goes uh what steps are you
willing to take to respond to the
economic impact of the war in our
country is it possible to use the loans
of the next generation funds and is it
possible to lower
fuel taxes and we would be very grateful
if we could have an answer in spanish as
well thank you
thank you thank you jackie for your
questions
first of all i think i think it's
crucial to to be united
this is what we are showing today with
the prime minister of latvia prime
minister of canada secretary general of
nato
spain and all the allies uh
in nato and the european union and that
is why i think it's important not to
you know to advance different measures
that we are uh going to uh we're going
to debate in in the council in in the
coming days in in paris but of course
economic sanctions
is
one of the most
powerful means instruments that we have
in order to stop this terrible and
unjustified
war that putin is
you know
making against against a
free country such as ukraine
uh secondly uh of course i think it's
it's it's very important to act uh
regarding the economic impact in spain
and of course in the world economy and
especially in the european economy
i think it's important to
to to act in in different in different
dimensions first of all the multilateral
dimensions and here we have
countries that belong to the g7 but of
course at the european level i think
it's important the communication that
the commission has released today
regarding the
energy policy which is one of the major
tools for the economic growth and of
course it is already impacting this
crisis on the uh
energy prices
and the and of course i think it's
important also to have this unity among
parties in
in spain and of course this unity that
we have shown with the
trade unions and enterprises
first with the pandemic and the response
the economic response to this pandemic
recovery 19th pandemic and of course
nowadays with this terrible and
unjustified war and
led by by putin so
this is this is the question
of the answer in in english and in this
video
is
is
[Music]
thank you so much and television just
very shortly my question to mr sanchez
you already mentioned that you decided
to send more troops to latvia could you
please be a little bit specific about
when they could arrive thank you so much
thank you very much actually we we've
been uh committed with a with latvia for
for long and the command of
the canadian army
and we are going to deploy as i said
before 150 new
soldiers here in the in this space and
it's it's going to be very very quick
very fast since
the nato
secretary general of course the
commander asked us to deploy as fast as
we can
these military units
thank you
good afternoon uh secretary general what
would nato do if vladimir putin
encroached on even one centimeter of
native territory and mr trudeau would
you be willing to go to war
we are here to deter
any attack on any nato allied country
and uh
deterrence has helped to preserve peace
for more than 70 years and now we are
stepping up to send an even stronger
message to
president putin that an attack on one
ally will trigger the response from the
whole alliance so we are here to protect
every inch of allied territory of latvia
and all other nato countries
and the purpose of that deterrence is
not to provoke a war but it is to
prevent the war it is to pursue peace
and uh uh when we see the aggressive
actions of
president putin against ukraine uh it
has led to
the
a big reinforcement to our presence in
latvia and also in other parts of
the eastern flank of our alliance
and i would like to commend canada spain
uh and also a lot to ask the host nation
for really
demonstrating unity demonstrating
commitment to our collective defense
and
as long as we stand together north
america and europe and nato
we are all safe because we are
by far the strongest alliance in history
and uh
the unity is much stronger than
president putin expected he wants less
nato he's getting more nato he wanted to
divide those is getting more united
alliance so uh we are here to preserve
peace prevent war and that's the reason
why we are increasing our defensive
deterrence presence in latvia and in the
rest of the eastern part of the alliance
vladimir putin
vladimir putin made a terrible mistake
vladimir putin made a fundamental
miscalculation he thought ukraine was
weak
and he thought nato was divided
he's been shown how wrong he is
ukrainians are strong and courageous and
standing up to defend their land
and nato has never been more united and
determined than we all now we are now
and i know i can speak for all nato
members when i say we will all abide by
article five
[Music]
press conferences
okay
uh
uh
[Music]